today I'm going to be speaking with
Matthew remsky who's a freelance
journalist writing about religious cults
and also co-host of the conspirituality
podcast is that the way you say it or is
it Khan's spirituality we usually
de-emphasize the first syllable but we
can talk about why
um I mean conspirituality is good so let
I mean I think that will will give us a
good kind of entry point into some of
the subject matter that you talk about
just to pick something and every time I
I Broach these topics invariably there
are people in my audience who get upset
sometimes misunderstanding what I'm
saying about whether it be Homeopathy or
yoga or Reiki or cupping or whatever
okay but just to pick something because
you have some experience with it let's
talk a little bit about yoga yoga is
interesting because it is a form of sort
of exercise and a physical a practice
and also tied in with it is some woo
sometimes and a spirituality element and
some practitioners just like you see
with different modalities will make more
claims than others about the supposed
benefits of something like yoga so let's
start there I mean what talk about your
experience with yoga benefits of the
practice that we know are evidence-based
and where things sometimes go beyond
that well I'm glad that you're starting
here because I've done a lot of years
doing cultural criticism on Yoga and
Wellness and the Cults associated with
them and sometimes I do forget the
benefits what actually got me interested
in the first place why this is a thing
why it's a huge industry uh and I think
you know the the evidence question is
actually quite
um you know the the the cards are the
judgment is still not in because it's
very difficult to do science on yoga but
I think the basic benefits that
everybody agrees on is that you can use
postures and stretching and mindful
breathing to get more familiar with your
bodily reality uh and maybe befriend it
a little bit more and I think for most
Global North you know American European
practitioners there was a time in which
those simple benefits were basically the
focus of what the practice had to offer
there was a period in the 70s the elite
60s maybe when yoga was largely
associated with simply loosening up
one's body and psychology becoming more
receptive and creative and maybe even
supporting the project of reimagining
society in gentler terms and a lot of
people would have transformative moments
with the postures and breathing they
might let go of of certain patterns of
social conditioning and expectations I
was a kind of exercise of mellowing out
or even dropping out but that's actually
between you know this sort of rigid
post-war Don Draper era fordist economy
and then you know Gordon Gekko starting
to get to the gym in the 1980s with a
kind of just do it physical culture that
begins to integrate with yoga in a very
profound manner where yoga becomes
something that you do to become more
self-sufficient not necessarily more
open or empathetic with other people and
I think strange actually when that
happened
some of it happening through till today
yoga as a culture began to remember and
even emphasize some of the early 20th
century themes that tied it to Fascism
for example which I'm sure we'll get
into
but the benefits are simple you know
like if you stay away from Instagram and
Lululemon and Psychopaths like Bikram
choudhary like everybody can have a late
1960s yoga moment because it's not the
clothes or the technique or the
alignment it's not green smoothies it's
just you know breathing deeply through a
choreography of postures focusing on
Sensations and emotions that can give a
lot of relief especially if you're
extremely online overly extroverted you
know disconnected with your body they're
really simple gifts you can enjoy them
at home without becoming compulsive or
without turning yoga into some kind of
like side hustle in a gig economy which
is what a lot of gen xers like myself
and then also Millennials actually did
For Better or Worse right so there's all
these other areas that we could explore
there's the kind of commoditizing yoga
uh into the franchise is business a
for-profit and sort of like that aspect
of it there's the way in which what you
just talked about is the benefits start
to be kind of built upon more and more
and more sometimes by charismatic for
lack of a better term what become cult
leaders in some cases and and we've
talked about that there's all these
different directions that we could go
with this let's maybe start with the
latter a little bit what are the sorts
of promises about yoga that sometimes
are made which then open the door down
to the more sort of like cult-like
aspects of this well I would say that um
the promises are totalizing in the yoga
world that not only is it about health
and wellness but there's also this
spiritual element that is spoken about
um it's part of a self-project that many
teachers will also speak about being
related to you know a global Awakening
of Consciousness this was very big
through the 60s and 70s
um and you know it's part of a general
historical turn away from you know
Community participation and towards the
self project and so ideas of personal
health and you know heightening your
immunity and you know avoiding
conventional medicine become wrapped up
in this as well
and the problem is is that is that like
the definitions for what yoga practice
is are very vague very subjective
um it's not like there are any real
standards for how we can assess the
competence of yoga teaching
um and what tends to rise to the top in
terms of Industry leadership is you know
you used the word before is the
charismatic you know in the absence of
being able to really sort of prove that
you are a competent or a even a safe
yoga teacher what you can do is you can
show that you perform the appearance of
equanimity or even Enlightenment really
well now that all gets heightened in the
visual age of Instagram of course but
the problem with Charisma is that you
know not all charismatics become cult
leaders but all cult leaders are in some
way charismatic and Charisma is kind of
like this organizational principle
people in the cultic dynamic where
there's some sort of mysterious
undefined power that a single person or
idea has at the center of a group and
that draws sort of energy towards that
power center uh and away from you know
Mutual Aid and sharing and horizontal
relationships what are some of the
warning signs if you're in and we can
stick with yoga but we could talk about
elsewhere what are some of the warning
signs that you might not be going to
just like a yoga class but this may be
more of the one that's that's the
cult-like thing
yeah I mean Silver Bullet claims about
your health uh about your physical
health your mental health
um the teacher who suggests that such
and such a posture is good for the
reproductive system or for liver
cleansing or for depression
um these are all medical claims and they
are they are absolutely ubiquitous
throughout the yoga World in fact like
the primary textbook
um written in 1966 by bksiengar is
called light on yoga
um and it's like I don't know 300 600
pages long or maybe it's 300 pages long
with 600 plates but every single posture
has an unsubstantiated medical claim
attached to it right that emerges out of
a you know an earlier time it's not like
this guy is a charlatan trying to pull
wool over people's eyes but there's this
General sort of epistemological
um I don't know lack of rigor in the
industry that ends up you know confusing
the pleasures of stretching and deep
breathing with feeling like there's some
sort of magical healing going on and so
you know Silver Bullet claims are a real
red flag I would also say that you know
there's a feeling of you know I don't
know uh contradictory
authoritarianism versus personal
autonomy I I would call it like the Tony
Robbins lie right like like you pay me
and you do exactly what I say and you'll
experience total personal freedom
um as long as you keep paying me and
doing exactly what I say exactly yeah
right um then there's the problem of of
intrusive eye contact which I think
people can identify if you know if
they're on YouTube now they can flip
over to Teal Swan and see how she does
that
um and then there's humorlessness I have
never ever met a wellness influencer or
yoga grifter or yoga cult leader I've
never encountered anybody in that whole
Echelon that has a sense of humor that
can laugh at themselves they're just
really puffed up and defensive and
usually anxious because I think usually
what they're what they're selling is
built on nothing you know as in hearing
you talk about some of the things you
mentioned I've had not with the the
later characteristics here but when I've
gone to massage therapists which I don't
do often because I find it all a little
bit awkward and I also really don't like
the oil which gets everywhere I'll tell
you
um I often they will it'll be a
completely you know find massage and
then at the end they'll say you know
massage can release a lot of toxins into
the body so make sure to drink a lot of
water to then flush them out and
immediately I'm thinking wait a second
so water we're talking about kidneys
some toxins are processed through the
liver you massage me and I lit Google is
there any scientific basis for that and
of course there is no scientific basis
for that right but it's just kind of
part of the whole experience it's and
it's it's so casually inserted in there
I think one of the things that's going
on in that encounter too is that they're
saying you're going to be sore after
they just manhandled you and I think you
should take care of yourself and
actually this kind of soreness or even
Afterglow of pain is part of something
that's good and and it establishes I'm
not saying the person is trying to rip
you off but I think it establishes the
kind of
um thought process by which you think oh
the consumer begins to feel like oh uh
something is coming out of me I'm in a
process of purification yeah I'm getting
straight with myself I'm renewing myself
I'm shedding my old skin and that's a
kind of Rhythm that can be really easily
monetized I think because often the
answer to soreness from massage is more
massage right in the same way that that
the answer to pain from yoga is often
presented as doing more yoga right what
um what happened during the pandemic
that sent this is not unique to yoga but
we can talk about it that way if it's
more you know if you're more precise in
that particular category that kind of
sent yoga folks down into the conspiracy
Rabbit Hole in some other areas
well a lot of things happened uh that
flowed together to really create a
perfect storm
um we have a lot of people who are
suddenly locked out of their places of
Wellness but also sometimes
um you know spiritual worship and
they're starting to spend all of their
time at home online the online space is
very flat very competitive
um you know March and April of 2020 you
couldn't go onto Facebook without seeing
like 25 people in my feed offering yoga
classes out of their dining room on
Facebook live and trying trying to get
paid by venmo now the the industry and
the community already is susceptible to
conspiracy theories to magical thinking
to a kind of well let's define the term
conspirality which is a an integration
or an intersection between political
conspiracy theorizing and New Age
Promises of wellness and renewal right
and it's not just an intersection it's
kind of like the two things are
dependent it's because things are so bad
in the world that we are being called to
awaken it's because they are developing
vaccines at a very fast rate that we
urgently must improve our immune system
so that we don't get microchipped so
there's kind of like a a you know sort
of a media strip of anxiety and promises
that begin to take over the online space
and what people found was that the
closer they got towards you know literal
Q Anon fever dream conspiracy material
the more popular they became
and we have a number of examples of
people who who vastly increase their
followings because they started pill you
know posting red pill material
now what happened and what was quite
tragic was that they might have had an
affinity for these ideas
um but it's not like they had full
commitment or necessarily knew exactly
that oh this this is a blood libel
fantasy oh this is actually part of the
satanic Panic that's being extended from
the 1980s they may not have been aware
of any of that but by the time they
invested their online identities with
you know promoting that material some of
them really lost a lot of contact with
not only their business you know sort of
uh Market but also with their families
um and so I did a lot of reporting on
the follow-up after that first acute
phase and there was a lot of people who
were like I really you know I don't
really believe in in Q Anon and I want
to with you know I I was just trying to
share information and uh I really just
want to do the yoga and of course then
there's a some small percentage of
people who are still sort of building
their brand on this very anxious and
very potent mix of conspiracy theories
and spiritual promises like the world is
terrible and here's the spiritual answer
which has to be which has to be total
it's not just that you're going to avoid
the the vaccines it's that you're going
to look into my eyes and we're going to
experience the the face of God together
and everything's going to be okay
last thing I want to ask you about what
are some new new age or spiritual things
that are going on that maybe I or my
audience haven't heard of because
there's so you know I find these
fascinating in a lot of different ways
and we've talked about everything from
you know crystals to
um I mean just all these different
things what's the new stuff that's
coming up now uh you know we have a
correspondent on our podcast named
Mallory DeMille and she's The Tick Tock
correspondent and so she looks into
things like you know the Healey
biofeedback machine and she looks into
light language tick talkers and we might
send her on a a neo-pagan hunt
um we also also there's a very
disturbing Trend developing on Tick Tock
that um involves a lot of conspiracy
theories amongst very young people who
consider themselves to be starseeds or
alien children or indigo children who
believe that 2023 is actually a
portentous time uh for for world
destruction and they're folding in sort
of weird stories about the weather
balloons and UFOs and the trains but
that's basically just end time stuff
right stuff yeah but but things on Tick
Tock can can accelerate at an alarming
Pace uh and and and get people really
revved up but I mean what I have
resolved to do after spending like three
years now in the mud of this stuff is I
tried to look for like spiritual
organizations or movements that
um are trying to sort of account for
this material they're trying to do
something and you know sometimes it's
hard to find uh places where I I feel
like oh I would attend that or yeah are
there any well you know when whenever I
come into I don't want to endorse
anybody directly but but whenever I come
into contact with something that makes
sense uh that feels like it's grounded
in reality you know it's going to be
like a black church it's going to be a
First Nations ceremony Community it's
going to be like an lgbtq plus support
group like anything that's just purely
associated with self-help or self-work
or the self project I just don't find
very compelling uh anymore personally
and I also think it remains vulnerable
to this kind of like hyper in
individualistic very reactionary
politics inviting and and soaked kind of
environment uh that that I just find
really toxic I mean I don't know what
the human spirit is uh but I I do find
that the people who are creating the
deepest sources of meaning are in these
groups that are doing something to sort
of account for their place in society to
resist some of the excesses of late
capitalism you know they're debating the
best ways forward and transparent ways
they focus on everyday work and you know
just normal things like parenting and
Community Care well I'm reading between
the lines and I'm not hearing an
endorsement for Deepak Chopra in what
you're saying no you're not you're not
actually because because there's
something extremely elitist and
unaffordable yeah aside from the
pseudosciences aside from aside from his
his relationships with you know
influencers who are peddling all kinds
of of conspiracy stuff uh yeah it's it's
just inaccessible and I think that's
good actually yes strange way it should
be more difficult to get sucked into it
I agree with that right we've been
speaking with Matthew remsky co-host of
the conspirituality podcast also a
freelance journalist really appreciate
your time and insights today thank you
David thank you so much